-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian who's about to kick off
her national "Ya Girl Done Made
It" stand-up tour.
For ticket information,
go to mspatcomedy.com.
She also created and stars in
"The Ms. Pat Show."
The third season is streaming
now on BET+.
Let's take a look.
-Get the [bleep] off me!
Oh, I know you ain't just
knocked me off this bed.
They got bugs down here,
and it stink.
It smell like old meat stuck in
my teeth.
I'm calling my agent.
'Cause my manager ain't managing
[bleep].
-In fairness, I'd just like to
say I'm a recovering alcoholic.
-Unh-unh, honey.
You done had three months
to use that alcoholic excuse.
You just [bleep] up.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Ms. Pat.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back, Ms. Pat.
-Oh, so happy to be back.
-You know, last time you were
here, we were talking about how
thanks to your success and
everything going so well
for you that your husband
retired.
-Yeah, and I told you he bought
a drone that he couldn't use.
-Yeah.
-Now he's recording the evening
news and waking up
like it's new news.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like, "People got
killed today."
I'm like, "No, that was
last night.
Stop recording the evening news,
okay?"
-So he tapes the evening news
and watches it in the morning?
-'Cause he go to bed at 6:30.
[ Laughter ]
-So, it sounds like he may be
having trouble keeping busy?
-No, he ain't having trouble
keeping busy.
He went out and bought
three big dogs, Seth.
-Okay.
-Cane corsos.
And I'm like, "What are we going
to do with these big old dogs?"
I mean big dogs.
And he cooks for them.
So, I walk in the house,
and he cooking chicken feet.
I'm like, "My mama used to love
chicken feet."
Because my mama didn't have no
front teeth and it was easy
for the feet to go in
and out her mouth.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is very helpful.
If you're missing
two front teeth,
you want a chicken foot that'll
just go in and out.
-Go in and out.
-Oh, that's helpful. Great.
-And I can say that
'cause she's dead
and she can't hear us.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-You got to be careful what you
say about Black mamas.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-And so, we got these three big
dogs, and I'm like,
"You just could've went out
and got kids.
You know, at least we could file
them on our income taxes."
-Yeah.
-And they from the same litter,
so they brothers and sisters.
-Here's a look at these dogs.
Look at these dogs.
These are big dogs. Alright.
-Oh, they're only 4 months old,
so they're going to get bigger.
They're going to be fat
like the rest of my family.
[ Laughter ]
And so, these dogs are so big,
and, like, one of them jumped in
the bed with me
and hit me upside the head.
I started having a flashback
like a belt was hitting me.
[ Laughter ]
And I told my husband, like,
"These dogs require healthcare."
When I had a dog, you could tie
them up to the tree.
You can't tie a dog
up to the tree now.
And these are some boujee dogs
too.
You know, you put -- one of them
have a -- he won't go to sleep.
All night just pressing on
his toy.
So I walk in there.
And, you know, I'm a Black mama.
I talk to my kids
not like you do.
So I take the broom.
[ Laughter ]
You do time-out.
I take the broom and hit the
cage, "Shut your damn mouth!"
[ Laughter ]
-How is that going?
Are they responding well?
-They're responding
like Black kids. "Yes, ma'am."
[ Laughter ]
-But it's expensive to feed
them.
-There's three of them.
A girl and two boys.
-What are their names?
-Zeus, Kong, and Sheba.
So, one of them done got in
heat.
But they brothers and sisters.
And you don't want the brother
to touch the sister.
But they don't know they
brothers and sisters.
So, he done put the dog on my
daughter panties.
And I'm like, "You don't think
this dog know
how to slide it to the side?"
[ Laughter ]
What man don't know
that old trick?
[ Laughter ]
So now we got the dog running
around with girl panties on.
I'm like,
"That's not gonna help."
[ Laughter ]
You're going to have to put on
a panty liner to keep her off.
[ Laughter ]
-Did you have dogs growing up
when you were a kid?
-I had one dog named Pup-Pup.
And Ronald Reagan killed my dog.
-What?
Ronald Reagan killed your dog?
-Yeah. We Democrats,
so he got re-elected,
and the dog jumped out
the back porch.
[ Laughter ]
That's why I'm a Democrat.
That's a true story.
-Oh, that's a true story?
Jumped out --
Like jumped off the porch?
-We was listening to
the election.
I'll never forget it,
on a little radio.
And he said, "Your new president
is Ronald Reagan."
And my dog jumped out
the back porch.
[ Laughter ]
My dog was like,
"Y'all didn't have no Alpo
the first four years.
I know y'all ain't going to have
none the next four."
[ Laughter ]
-You're so busy.
I'm so impressed.
You've got your show.
You've got your podcast.
-Yes.
-You've got radio.
-You're going on tour.
But tell me, what's
your daily routine?
What time do you get started?
-I wake up every morning about
3:00.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Because he snore like a horse.
-Yeah.
-So I get up in the morning
and I do TikTok.
I love TikTok.
-You love TikTok?
-Oh, I just --
[ Woman claps ]
Thank you, ma'am.
[ Laughter ]
TikTok will make you buy things
that you can't even fit.
[ Laughter ]
I'll be on there buying clothes
your size.
[ Laughter ]
I'll be buying four sweaters.
And I tell my girl to put
these sweaters together.
[ Laughter ]
-So you're very susceptible to
advertising when you see it?
You just jump right in?
-I like buying things.
Like, I bought a $2,000 faucet
'cause my husband bought
a thousand dollars worth of dog.
[ Laughter ]
But he don't think
I need the faucet.
I'm like,
"You don't need the dog.
Do you know how much cold water
is going to come out
of this faucet?"
You know all my girlfriends are
going to come over like,
"Oh, my God, look at
this faucet."
I'm like, "Yeah, $2,200."
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I'm a Black kid
from the hood.
I got a little money now.
I don't know how to act.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You got that faucet money.
-I bought two of them.
-You bought two?
-Yeah, but my husband's asleep,
so he ain't gonna see this show.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know one of your dreams --
and, again, with everything
you've got going on right now,
I don't know where you'll find
the time.
But you want to host
a game show.
And you have a very good idea.
-I want to host a newlywed game
but with grown people content.
Like say, for instance,
I've been married 30 years.
And we bring the mother-in-law
on there.
Everybody got a mother-in-law
from hell, right?
-Yeah.
-So, I get to tell
my mother-in-law that she look
like James Brown.
[ Laughter ]
She really do, and I was waiting
to tell her that, but she died.
So --
[ Laughter ]
But imagine if you could really
tell your in-laws or tell people
off that are a part of
your husband family.
And a lot of women
don't get to say it.
Mother-in-laws are the devil.
[ Laughter ]
-So you didn't have a good
relationship with yours?
-Not in the beginning.
Towards the end, she was okay.
You know, I used to give her
my food stamps.
And she still didn't like me.
-Really?
-Until I cussed her out.
I told her one day, "When you
help me sleep with this fat man,
then you can tell me
what to do."
[ Laughter ]
-How did she respond to that?
-She prayed.
[ Laughter ]
She was a Christian,
and I don't like Christians.
[ Laughter ]
They pray too much
for unnecessary stuff.
I don't want to hear that mess.
And God is busy.
That's how we lost Betty White.
They clogging up
the prayer line.
[ Laughter ]
-They were praying about
nonsense?
-Nonsense, Gucci belts, cars.
And God killed Betty White.
Forgot her birthday party
was coming up.
[ Laughter ]
I truly believe that.
-Congratulations.
Season 3 of "The Ms. Pat Show."
-Season 3.
-And you got to work with
Marla Gibbs,
talking about an American legend
right there.
-We got her to cuss.
-That's amazing.
You got Marla Gibbs to --
-I'm going to get you to cuss.
Come on over to BET+.
-Oh, man. I'll tell you this.
-He's an old man.
"I've never been there."
-I will, I will -- I will do --
I would do an episode of
"The Ms. Pat Show"
in a heartbeat.
Get me one of those tiny beds,
and we'll have a fun old time.
-I got -- You know it's
an all-white community.
I got something for you.
-Yeah. Alright, great.
There we go.
I'm a terrible actor,
but I would love to do it.
-Before I get out of here, can I
please tell you my owl story?
-Yeah.
-So, my girlfriend live
in the city of Atlanta.
And I'm sitting in her yard
one night on the phone.
You know, kind of in the hood
where they sell drugs
down the street.
And I'm just sitting there
on the phone.
But all of a sudden,
this thing starts floating
out of the air like Jesus.
I'm like,
"What the hell is that?"
I put on my bright light,
and it's a real owl.
And he turned his head around
and his eyes glowed up.
I said, "Oh, I don't mess
with nothing
that ain't got no damn neck."
[ Laughter ]
I put my car in reverse.
I said, "Bitch, you got an owl
in your yard!"
[ Laughter ]
It was the hood!
I never seen --
Those type of animals don't come
to the hood.
-Yeah.
-We do pit bulls
and cane corsos.
We don't do no damn owl!
[ Laughter ]
And he was flying like Jesus.
He hit that ground, I said,
"Hell to the no, no, no."
[ Laughter ]
-I'm very happy you shared
your owl story.
[ Laughter ]
-I've never seen him again
but I never --
I don't go back to my friend
house at nighttime.
[ Laughter ]
Mnh-mnh. I don't know
where she --
I don't know how an owl
got to the hood.
-Yeah. Well, it's probably
this Flaco one in Central Park.
-No, he not Flaco.
He had a gold chain on.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the great Ms. Pat,
everybody.
"Ms. Pat Show" streaming now on
BET+.
For information on her tour --
she's got a tour --
go to mspatcomedy.com.
We'll be right back with more
"Late Night."